[Musique]
voilà la plus jeune âge c'est vraiment
mal dit
à 14 ans le montargois jacob legault et
merveilles son entourage dès l'âge de 3
ans il monte sur une planche à neige et
on fait presque un mode de vie mais
avant de penser à une future
participation à la clique pratiquer son
sport c'est avant tout le plaisir de
s'envoler et de faire les plus belles
figures la page en ajouter je sais pas
si tu amusera autant dans la vie donc
choqué c'est vraiment moi et pour moi de
me tenir à l'écart de toutes les autres
problèmes puissent vivre ma vie
chaque homme c'est une boule d'énergie
je dirais d'accord tu vas le premier
arrivé à l'entraînement et puis le
dernier parti la période
son entraîneur max hénault qui a dans
son écurie plusieurs médailles
olympiques est dithyrambique quand il
parle de son jeune protégé professionnel
à 100% sûr il ya tout ce qu'il faut il
ya le caractère il ya la motivation et
la bonne humeur et à la compréhension
jacob legault s'entraîne à sainte agathe
des monts et il faut toi régulièrement
les médaillés olympiques de la nied jeu
de paume chante sébastien toutant
maxence parrot et la médaillée d'argent
l'horrible loin sur un jeune qui a du
potentiel s'il faut jouer à quel point
qui évolue vite puis je pense que c'est
quelqu'un à regarder ces symptômes
je suis vraiment le fun ii pour avoir la
chance de s'entraîner avec des athlètes
de haut niveau comme ça les jeux
olympiques
by jybo l'on vaut rendu leur revanche je
suis rendu là pour voir comment quai ça
va ce principe
en attendant jacob continue
d'impressionner et de progresser
même s'il sait que la route vers les
jeux de 2022 sera longue et que les
places sont peu nombreuses au fait
jacob signifie en hébreu celui qui
talonnera les champions olympiques
d'aujourd'hui ne pourront pas dire
qu'ils ne le savais pas
rozier radio canada à québec